that saudi arabia's influence on
American business and politics poses a
large threat to us security he spoke
about it recently at books and books in
Coral Gables Florida
for an hour good evening and welcome to
books and books we're having a wonderful
evening here tonight with a celebration
to welcome back the award-winning author
of why America slept Gerald Posner is
here tonight with his latest book the
secrets of the kingdom which will give
us a wonderful background on the
us-saudi connection Gerald is here in
the area lives on the beach he has a
wonderful back list of titles most of
which we have here tonight at books and
books and we're very happy to welcome
you here tonight
as well as Gerald back to address you
with this newest title let's give him a
great welcome thank you very much it is
wonderful to be back at books and books
I think that the last time I was here
was two years ago together with my wife
Trish we just had our 21st wedding
anniversary and last time we were here
was two years ago I was talking about
why America slept she was talking about
her books no hormones no fear about
going through menopause so it's sort of
a night of hormones and terror the now
tonight Trisha who helps work with me on
all my folks gets to sit down and not
have to deal with the Saudis at least
for the moment I really appreciate you
taking the time to come this evening
because this isn't necessarily the most
pleasant subject in the world I don't
have any secrets of how to make a
fortune in real estate I don't know how
to tell you what are the best stocks to
buy or or what to do for personal
happiness instead I'm talking to you
about a subject that isn't necessarily
the most uplifting in the world and I do
appreciate that
you take the time to come out and
actually listen on this matter I think
one of the greatest problems we have in
this country as a general overall
comment is the apathy that pervades
voters in state after state and so that
many people look at their political
leaders in Washington and state capitals
throw up their arms and think there's
little they can do to change the system
that's the wrong feeling about it I do
think that we have power eventually and
we have power even on issues of foreign
policy sometimes with the Saudis the one
of the things that I'd like to just
start with first second authors will
sometimes those of you have come to
other readings or talks or that know
that authors will occasionally give you
a quote or citation from a recent review
that they've had on their particular
book so that you know you may hear
something from from the New York Times
or The Washington Post or Curtis and
you'll say ah that must be really a
stellar book and if you'll bear with me
one second I'm just gonna give you a
couple of pull quotes recently about
secrets of the kingdom that you might
find interesting the Arab News said just
last week the lowest of the low a work
of great injustice and distortion
Riyadh's national radio said Posner is a
Shero nion writer now I never knew
Cherone could be used as an adjective in
this case Ashe Aronian writer the work
of our enemies the Saudi embassy issued
a most interesting official statement to
Fox News the and they still marvel at
this a pack of lies if you believe
Gerald Posner you have not only been
inhaling but you have been snorting as
well now I know that Arab in cells can
be flowery but I guarantee you that
something must have been lost in the
translation on on that one and the last
one is we just as a matter of fact two
days ago in dar Al Hayat one of the
largest english-language papers in the
Middle East the writer said when Gerald
Posner writes about Saudi Arabia I don't
see before me a writer and his book but
rather a man in a rubbish bin throwing
litter in the air and litter falling
back on his head so now that you're all
suitably impressed with the reception
for secrets of the kingdom no new york
times for me the only the very best
actually after why america slept Tricia
and I had thought that we would leave
the world of terror and radical Islam
and the last thing we thought we'd be
doing is probably a book about Saudi
Arabia and then the 9/11 Commission
report came out and we read it very very
carefully and there were just a few
things in there that got my blood
pressure going so much so that
eventually turned out to be a book on
the Saudis in our relationship with them
over years the things in the 9/11
Commission report the particularly
incensed me and I wrote an editorial as
a matter of fact an op-ed later in The
New York Times about a month after the
9/11 Commission report came out saying
that the Commission had given a pass a
free pass to the Saudis much to the
anger of the Commission members I think
the Commission did a great job when it
comes to the matters of what went wrong
in the lead-up to 9/11 the FBI the CIA
where the errors were made excellent but
what they didn't the Saudis wasn't as
good and give you just two three very
quick examples some of you may have seen
the Michael Moore film in Fahrenheit
9/11 Moore takes the flights that took
place of Saudis in the United States
immediately after 9/11 and then goes off
and makes quite a conspiracy based upon
them I think he goes too far afield but
there's a very interesting point in
which maybe the import I don't give as
much import to as Michael Moore does but
the fact itself is very interesting on
September 13th two days after the attack
on America there was a flight of private
jet of three Saudis that left from tamp
and flew up to Lexington Kentucky where
a group of Saudi royals were then
meeting they were buying racehorses and
they were about to leave the country a
couple of days later now a Tampa
reporter a local Tampa reporter did the
good work of uncovering that flight and
reported it about a month after 9/11 the
federal government for two years and I
go into this in the first chapter
adamantly denied bless you that flight
ever took place
the FAA said it's wrong it never took
place
I mean there are statements from fAA
officials saying you've got to have it
wrong it has to be the fourteenth
because nothing was flying on the 13th
private air the FBI said it Justice
Department officials said it now two
years after the denials just short of
two years the government flip-flopped
entirely and said oh by the way that fly
in the 13 it did happen on the 13 so I
waited for the 9/11 report to come out
to see what it would say about the
flight in the 13th and the 9/11 report
said the flight on the 13th of the three
Saudis from Tampa to Lexington is not
unusual out of the ordinary because
restrictions on aviation were lifted
that day now that's disingenuous at best
the 9/11 commissioners had to know that
that wasn't quite right on 913
restrictions on aviation that were
lifted were for commercial aviation only
delta american airlines u.s. air and
then only in limited cases in some
airports so for instance in New York's
two major airports LaGuardia and Kennedy
they were open in the morning and then
they were closed by one o'clock they
stayed closed for the entire day because
of security concerns
no private planes were allowed to fly in
the 13th for private planes that took
off from different airports were brought
down by military craft that forced them
to land and even private planes with
organ transplants that had been downed
on the 11th and had not been allowed to
fly were still not allowed to fly in the
13th to bring their organs to different
hospitals that were waiting for them for
people that might die the only flight in
the United States of a private plane of
the 13th of September was the flight of
the three Saudis from Tampa up to
Lexington now I'm convinced that those
three Saudis had nothing to do with 9/11
I've looked into them I've checked them
out they don't have a link so this
flight that took place two hours after
President Bush met with Prince Bandar
the Saudi ambassador to the United
States of the contents of which have
never been disclosed is a flight that
the 9/11 Commission should have had the
courage to have said we did our Saudi
friends a favor we allowed their
nationals to fly around the United
States at a time when no Americans were
allowed to fly and we allowed their
nationals to be the first to leave the
country two days later when no other
nationals
left the country but instead of saying
that they said well there was nothing
unusual because Aviation restrictions
had been lifted some of you who might be
familiar with my earlier book on why
America slept will know that in there
for the first time I disclosed the
contents of an interrogation with a top
al-qaeda suspect
Abu Zubaydah who was the field commander
for Osama bin Laden a field commander
that we ran down in March of 2002 in
Pakistan and he was wounded when he was
captured the Wenzhou Baida was taken
into custody he wouldn't even give his
name and the Americans wanted to know at
that time what do you know is there
another attack coming is something
taking place and they had a plan which
they thought was very clever to do a
false flag operation where they would
put him into a prison and make it appear
as though he was being held by another
country in the hope that he would be so
afraid of being held by that country for
torture and possibly execution that he
would want to talk to the Americans so
they fly him over to CIA compound in
Afghanistan they set him up I have the
details about this in disclosure for the
first time in the book in a compound in
which he believes he's being
interrogated by the Saudis and instead
of being afraid when he sees his quote
saudi interrogators they're really
Special Forces from the US Special
Forces he says in so many words oh great
to see you guys here call this number up
here's a private number and it turns out
to be the private cell phone number of
prince ahmed bin faisal bin abdulaziz
who is the 43 year old nephew of the
king of saudi arabia sort of like the
Rupert Murdoch of the kingdom he's the
biggest media holder in the country he
was in Lexington on September 11th he
was one of the Royals in Lexington
buying racehorses
he had a racehorse a few years ago won
the Kentucky Derby war emblem Americans
can't figure out what to do with that
information so they go back to zübeyde
and they say you're dirty liar and Joe
Biden says oh yeah called these numbers
up and gives more private telephone
number cell phone numbers and home phone
numbers from memory of two other Saudi
princes 41 year old military officer 25
year old compatriot of his and then he
gives the name of the head of Pakistan's
Air Force Musha poli mayor and his home
number and he says Ali Mir was our
contact al-qaeda's contact in Pakistan
for years and both the Kings nephew and
Ally mayor knew that there would be an
attack in America in September so don't
tell me that you can't get me out of
here now
when zubeida found out he was being held
by the Americans he recanted the entire
thing he said oh I was just making it up
fellows
I had these telephone numbers you know
stuck in my mind and I I just threw it
out to forestall torture and the
Americans couldn't figure out what to do
with it they investigated it for a month
they came to dead end so they went and
told the Saudis and Pakistanis what
zubeida have said both countries denied
it they said absolutely false a terrible
slander shortly after we told the Saudis
and Pakistanis all these four people had
bad misfortune bad luck
talk about bad days the 43 year old
nephew of the King Prince Achmed goes
into Saudi Hospital for what at the time
I thought was diverticulitis surgery is
sort of a bad stomach it turns out was
really the stomach stapling he wanted to
lose weight and he dies two days later
the Saudi doctor said heart attack then
they think it's a blood clot because he
wasn't active enough the next day after
Achmed dies the second printing buys a
bite of the 41 year old military officer
dies in a one car wreck his car goes off
the road in the desert in the Saudi say
he's driving too fast two days later the
third printing by zubeida dies the 25
year old my personal favorite the
official cause of deaths in the Saudi
royal court is of thirst I kid you not
the he dies 50 I you couldn't make this
up he dies 55 miles outside the Saudi
capital and his Rolls Royce forgetting I
guess to take a bottle of Evian along or
that in the Saudi desert heat and then
Musha folly mayor they had a Pakistan's
Air Force like our Joint Chiefs of Staff
goes up in his private military playing
with his wife and 15 of his top aides
aboard and the pilot is switched to the
last minute ear witnesses hear an
explosion the plane blows up and that's
the end of all Emir now I turn to the
9/11 report to the index as you can and
you won't see any of those four names
you'll seem to bite his name he's listed
and the 9/11 Commission talks about
access that it had to zübeyde his
interrogations but not in March not in
March the month that he's caught not in
March the month that he names these
three Saudis and names the Pakistani
head the first time they start two sites
abide as interrogations are in May in
June when they use him to support the
disclosures of yet another captured
al-qaeda leader Mohammed Sheikh
Hamid I thought to myself at the time if
the 9/11 report hasn't dealt with the
disclosures of a captured al-qaeda
terrorist leader who's naming Saudi
princes if they if they dismissed the
June 13th flight if they don't talk
about the issues of how money ended up
in two of the hijackers pockets which we
could talk about later through this
circuit US route that takes place from
the Saudi embassy then what they have
done is they either have not done an
adequate investigation on the Saudis
because they also said that we found no
evidence of official Saudi involvement
in the financing of terrorism of an
entire chapter I think that proves that
absolutely wrong at some of the highest
levels of the government including the
governor of Riyadh or they just did a
favor for our friends one more time and
what I think is most infuriating about
this book secrets of the kingdom is that
now that I understand better after the
last two years of doing this reporting
the nature of our relationship with
Saudi Arabia I'm not surprised at the
time I read the 9/11 report I was
outraged because I thought why and now I
realized that administration after
administration Democrat and Republican
from FDR not they've always dealt with
the Saudis kindly we've always given
them the benefit of the doubt and you
know we forget in some ways what a
remarkably new country doesn't mean war
new country but it's founded just a
little over 70 years ago in 1932 and he
was founded by a desert warrior eben
Saud who is a fierce desert warrior who
is head of the South clan or family and
he defeats every other desert clan and
eventually unifies the Arabian Peninsula
for the first time and says I'm gonna
call Arabia Saudi Arabia Arabia of the
sounds it's like Donald Trump taking
over a building and calling a trump
tower that and they they take it over
and he's enamored with the British royal
family so he calls himself King there's
no royal blood but it's fantastic in his
sticks and then every son is a prince
today there's six thousand male princes
and they made their money by taxing it
you know Muslim pilgrims who came in for
the Hajj to Mecca
that was their way of making money they
thought they might be able to survive
and then three years later after they
found the country they hit the lottery
it's like buying mega lottery or
whatever and you get the the one winning
ticket American geologist going around
the middle-east looking for oil discover
the biggest oil reserves in the world
sitting underneath the Arabian Peninsula
and suddenly the entire picture changes
an FDR has a meeting with a bin saud
aboard a u.s. naval vessel and it's a
remarkable event even sound brings goats
on and everything else to give to FDR
and it's just amazed FDR's wheelchair
which he has never seen before and wants
to know if it's something that can you
know give power to you it says fabulous
social meeting as well but at that
meeting was sort of the deal that was
made it's not a secret deal there's
nothing wrong with it but the deal was
we America will protect you you will be
our ally in the Middle East and and the
problem is that we were dealing with a
country that has based itself for the
last 70 years largely both on oil and
survives on religion I mean because the
interesting thing about the subs when
they took power was that they had made a
pact not in general not a general sense
like you say oh you know dear God help
me out today and I promise to be good
for the next week but they had made an
actual pact with a fellow called
Mohammed al Wahab that's where Wahhabi
ism comes from if you've heard of
Wahhabism was a real man it was a cleric
it was a wild-eyed cleric in the 1700s
who was looking to expand his very
austere version of Islam at a time when
there were many austere versions of
Islam but his was by far the strictest
and he literally did a handshake deal
with eben salves great-grandfather in
which he said we will do this together
combine my religious forces my Wahhabi
admire hobby acolytes together with your
family's fighting power and together we
will take this Peninsula it took them
200 years for both families to fulfill
that but the salads kept their promise
Mohave ism became the law of the land
the Quran is interpretation was the only
law there's no Constitution and the
religious police to this day control
education and they've controlled the
charities and the Saudi family is
involved integrally with that
theological
government there is part and parcel and
overtime it's created problems with the
United States has tried to deal with but
inevitably the souls have felt more and
more of their own power as we've become
increasingly dependent as an oil
dependent country of that cheap energy
and I say cheap even at fifty dollars a
barrel the in 1974 many of you remember
the oil embargo I remembered it in San
Francisco with the long lines of waiting
to get into gas lines and how oil price
suddenly went up the South had said in
74 something very interesting
you know we had resupplied Israel in the
73 war the arab-israeli war King Faisal
at the time I had this pathological
hatred there's a strong level of
anti-semitism in Saudi Arabia that is
from day one and there's a strong
anti-christian what they view as a
crusade or element they view Christians
as Crusaders in very strict Wahhabi sort
of theological interpretation but in in
terms of their anti-semitism King Faisal
was a king who in hotel rooms and there
weren't many foreigners visiting Saudi
Arabia at that time but those who were
visiting in your hotel room you would
get a copy an English copy of the
protocols of Zion which was the Czarist
forgery that Jews were about to take
over the world he even gave one to Henry
Kissinger when Henry Kissinger went over
to Saudi Arabia he got a copy the
protocols of Zion and a lecture about
how the Jews were gonna take over the
world when some a reporter wants to ask
Faisal but you know in the Middle East
the United States is supporting you say
the Jews are Bolsheviks and the Jews are
behind the international communist
conspiracy but in the Middle East it's
Russia and the Soviet Union supporting
Syria and Egypt in the United States
supporting Israel he said but it's all a
game it's like you know it's like
professional wrestling they're just
pretending to be against each other it's
all part of the same conspiracy so there
was this real feeling of anti-semitism
and when Nixon resupplied Israel salad
was the one who led the effort the
following year to say let's punish them
we can punish the United States we can
use our oil as a weapon one of the
interesting things is Frank youngers who
was then the American head of Aramco
was called in in a situation that's been
described before in which I described in
this book into the by the King into his
palace and the King said we're going to
boycott Americ
we're gonna boycott the six feet in the
seventh feet we're gonna keep oil from
flowing into Europe and we're gonna make
sure that you know the Western powers
are punished for what they did with
Israel and at that point Aramco the
American oil companies the four
conglomerate really were responsible for
getting the oil out of the ground and
putting into the barrels and shipping
and collecting the fees and then they
would give the Saudis royalty
so Frank younger said how are you gonna
do this you know your your highness and
he said I'm not you are
and Aramco was faced with this very
tough decision of what to do and they
went along with the Saudis to large part
that that boycott was effective and made
the Saudis feel the price and the power
of their product so that the following
year 1975 they said to us look we have a
hundred and forty billion dollar plan to
rebuild the kingdom into a modern
country almost overnight now coming in
bid for this work all you companies were
interested Rockwell Boeing you know come
on over we're here we're open for
business unless you happen to have too
many Jews on your letterhead you're
doing business with Zionists or you're
doing business with Israel and therefore
you're boycotted because you know we
have an official boycott against anybody
like that and what did American
companies do this is a remarkable thing
the Commerce Department looked into this
in the late 70s and finally came out
with the statistics over lawsuit over
1500 major American companies you can go
down the list went along and complied
with the Saudi rules that they not send
Jews to Saudi Arabia that they not do
business with Israel architectural firms
took off the Jewish names from the top
of their letterhead they cut out
projects that showed they had done
business for Jewish leaders so that they
could not so they could get some of the
business inside of the kingdom and the
kingdom and forced those rules for years
until anti-boycott laws for finally
passed in the United States we would
have said to any other country we're not
going along with it but the lure of the
dollar the lure of the profits was so
great that we did in fact go along in
the 1980s the Saudis were there they
were helping us behind the scenes what
were they doing they were sending half a
billion dollars a year to the Afghan
rebels we love that because they were
made the Soviet Union until quagmire in
Afghanistan was tying up the biggest
power around
they sent 32 million dollars down to the
iran-contra they sent some of the arms
over to as I ear at the time decided to
fight anti-soviet to help anti Soviet
militias they sent some money to south
Africa because we had asked them to do
so so Saudis would play a game with us
and they also became increasingly good
what you'll see in here what I call the
Wahhabi Lobby you know Israel has
purchased warms at any other country on
the planet from the United States that
may not surprise you what might surprise
you the second largest purchaser of all
time is Saudi Arabia so Saudi Arabia
loses its battles occasionally in
Congress sometimes it doesn't get us
f-16s sometimes it doesn't get
everything but it gets its AWACS
eventually it does get the jet fighters
and it knows how to play the game in
Washington as well as anybody it hires
the former officials everybody from Jim
West the former governor down the
Carolinas it has got the senator William
Fulbright it brought in Spiro Agnew it
gets the former heads of the CIA it
hires them on their payroll nothing
wrong with it former government
officials go to work for companies and
register all the time as agents but the
Saudis do it the prince bandar they're
very effective at lobbying and
eventually you'll be surprised at the
amount they get through Congress one of
the things that I think is interesting
about Saudi Arabia is that they are very
very effective at playing what I call
both sides of the fence you know George
Bush said after 9/11 you are the with us
or against us in the case of the Saudis
in to a lesser extent Pakistan is a bit
of both ways they're with us and against
us you know people ask me sometimes
friend or foe and depends on what day of
the week it is I mean there are days
when they are a friend and days when
they are foe it's a very schizophrenic
relationship and part of the reason that
we tend to be confused by them I believe
is that the Saudis that we deal with
here in the United States seem really
like one of us what I mean by that give
you an extreme example Prince Bandar the
Saudi ambassador to the United States he
dresses in not that we all dressed in
$3,000 Savile Row tailored suits this is
not one of them but he dresses in the
finest tailored suits he's been to
Oxford and Cambridge he's got it he
speaks English better than I do
he has a 65,000 square foot home in
Aspen where he invites people up to go
skiing during the winter he plays tennis
with the Joint Chiefs of Staff he plays
golf with Colin Powell if you have him
over for a dinner party
he's got a fabulous sense of humor
yourself to tell self-deprecating
stories about the king and you
look at him and you think this isn't
Osama bin Laden this isn't an extremist
I don't understand this concept of
Wahhabism he's one of us he's a
westerner who has a great amount of
money and therefore is enjoying the best
of Western lifestyle and we forget that
when they fly back to Riyadh they put on
the traditional robes and they go into
the mosque on Friday and they listen to
sometimes two lectures and they go to a
school system that preaches a hatred
against the West that the State
Department has for the past ten years
been trying to correct and since 9/11
has finally started to make some
progress on and some of you might have
heard just three weeks ago the US
military announced not a starting
statistic to us but a lot of people seem
to be surprised by it that 42 percent of
the suicide bombers in Iraq who have
been identified DNA and body parts have
not been Iraqis but have been Saudis
blowing themselves up from 13 year-old
Saudi kids to Saudi doctors who have
been going into the mosque on Fridays
and hearing the sermons about the
Crusader being next door even though
this is supposed to be our ally in the
fight on terror who's supposed to have
toned down the rhetoric inside the
kingdom and they're getting so incensed
they're crossing the border and they're
actually committing suicide to be able
to stop us in our taking over of Iraq
and making it into a Christian nation
and an outpost inside the Middle East a
second sort of foothold after Israel in
this book you'll also find something I
think that the Saudis are particularly
incensed with and that is a chapter that
I called petrol scorched earth or it's
the name of a file inside the National
Security Agency I'll just very quickly
tell you that is based upon electronic
intercepts of Saudi officials from the
embassy in Washington to officials back
in the capital of Riyadh and together to
members the royal family starting in
1986 at a time when the Saudis were
somewhat worried about Iran being a
threat to them rounds embroiled with the
war in Iraq they're getting desperate of
times the ayatollahs were taken only
over in 1979 they threw the scheie out
the ayatollahs hate the Saudi royal
family they preached against them all
the time they say they're corrupt
terrible
family in that the Iranians should for
the Shia branch of Islam take back Mecca
and Medinah Saudis are worried enough
that they start to talk about what do we
do in case the Iranians come in about
our oil fields we don't want to give it
over to them and this is very
interesting this is a concept that we as
Westerners really have to understand the
Saudis believe that that House of Saud
at least believes that those oil fields
were given to them by all forget the
fact that dinosaurs had to die there 2
million years ago and events he had a
formed the entire process that
eventually led to this great earth but
they believed that they took it over
1932 and the Prophet therefore a loud
oil be discovered in 35 and that they
have built up this tremendous
infrastructure it's an amazing
infrastructure they have the 750 mile
pipeline as their facilities are
hundreds of acres Biggers very
sophisticated it's not just oil wells
here and there and there feeding was we
were given this it's our birthright
we've created the infrastructure to
produce it and sell it we're not going
to give it to our enemies the Iranians
if they come in just like Sodom was
saying when he left Kuwait set oil fires
as he was leaving it to make it
difficult they thought what can we do so
they started to talk about placing
conventional bombs at some of what they
have is their panacea targets the big
open targets that would really slow up
an advancing army then in the early 90s
in ninety Saddam Hussein invades Kuwait
and it's how he's really get nervous
about losing the oil fields so they
invite us the infidel and to protect
them in terms of the army but they also
go further in terms of thinking what
they can do to now put explosives inside
their own system and according to these
intercepts in the early 90s 91 and 92
they placed a series of conventional
bombs at key points along the
infrastructure together with what they
called rdd's radiological dispersal
devices that would let off small levels
of radiation that wouldn't kill anybody
the equivalent of what we call a dirty
bomb but would contaminate certain areas
of the infrastructure so the people
could not get in for several years to
fix them now here's the question the NSA
doesn't know the NSA is not sure whether
this systems in place as the Saudis have
said on these intercepts or whether the
Saudis knowing that they might have been
listened to by Western intelligence were
like good poker players and made it
sound even better than it was in the
hope that if they started to fall
leading rised
would be so nervous that they were about
to blow up the infrastructure of the
world's greatest oil producer we would
rush over to save them there are two
things about it that make it very
interesting the semtex that was used in
91 and 92 that the Saudis used was
unmarked semtex it has a 20 year shelf
life so at the very worst case scenario
we have to live to 2011 or 2012 with the
possibility that we could lose a third
of the world's oil supply if things go
badly in the Middle East after that the
useful life of the explosives are over
and the system is useless before that we
could send it in international
inspectors that old phrase international
inspectors Iraq it sounds too familiar
to look at the Saudi infrastructure not
their military secrets not their
military but to look at specifics in
which I named in this book I talked
about I've checked the biggest of the
oil processing facilities and in there
say that three of the ten cylinders are
rigged those ten cylinders that are
enormous they're almost like a football
field in size at some point those can be
checked there's an absolute truth to
whether this exists in its full or
whether it doesn't but the Saudis have
adamantly denied it and not only that
but just a week ago this past Thursday
in Vienna at a meeting of the
International Atomic Energy Commission
they asked for an exception now they
have signed the non-proliferation to a
pact that's great but they asked for an
exception from anybody coming in to look
at their country for even nuclear
devices they said we think that we
should have an exemption is a developing
country that we should be able to have
small amounts of radiation and plutonium
in our country as long as we don't have
a weapons building program and we don't
want inspectors coming in to look at any
armor for our facilities so the question
I have is post 9/11 what will the Bush
administration or any future
administration do about this issue you
might remember them when we're dealing
with Iraq George Bush said we can't be
sure let's say we can't be sure on the
weapons of mass destruction in Iraq in a
post-911 world we can't err on the side
of being wrong we have to assume that if
weapons of mass destruction are in fact
there and could fall into the hands of
terrorists it's too dangerous not to be
aggressive on this front so my question
is regarding the House of Saud we have
gone over with members of the Treasury
to
and given them a list of things to do to
cut back on the money laundering and the
funding of extremism and terrorism and
they've implemented a few of them but
for the rest of them they just continue
to ignore them and they say we'll get to
them eventually we ask them continuously
to open up the country to a little bit
of political reform they had elections
in February for a provincial council it
sounded like they were really moving
forward you've probably seen that half
the council was elected half was
appointed by the king they can't make
any they have no decision-making power
at all they can only give advice and
then the King gets the final say of
those that were running of course women
couldn't vote fourteen percent of the
eligible voters finally voted the
religious Fundamentalist were those who
were elected to office so that was the
their extended looking at a democracy
three prominent writers came out two
weeks ago and protested those
parliamentary elections and said there
were a sham they should be open up to a
much wider group of Saudis including
women and we should have new elections
you know what happened to them they were
given a quick trial and sentenced to six
to eleven years in prison but you don't
hear one thing from the State Department
protesting human rights abuses inside of
Saudi Arabia because we are afraid of
insulting our good allies the Saudis the
problem in Washington is that if you go
and talk to the people in power they
believe the only options are either the
House of Saud with all its corruption
and its hold on Mojave ism or an Islamic
fundamentalist government like an Osama
bin Laden and a Taliban type government
so they said the sounds may not be that
good but they're better than the
alternative and I'm convinced those
aren't the only two alternatives that
there is a way if the United States was
aggressive enough with it to slowly push
the more progressive and reformist
elements in the south family to open up
that country a little bit for reform not
western-style democracy but little bits
of reform on human rights and other
issues in the standing of women so that
eventually they aren't going to have an
explosion from the bottom that will
throw them out of power like the Shah of
Iran fell you know the king is sick he's
the king is 83 years old King Fahd he
was in the hospital recently they
thought he might die and then he pulled
out he had a stroke in 1980 1995
he's been wheelchair-bound since then
the country's run by the crown prince
abdullah that's who was holding george
bush's hand down and Crawford who was
the crown prince not the king when the
King dies Abdul
we'll take power officially he'll become
the king and the crown prince will most
likely be it's hard to you know this
salads don't have an official line of
succession but it'll probably be the
defense ministers Sultan who's 79 so
we're not talking about the youngest
fellows in the world taking over the
kingdom the real question is what
happens after them the next generation
of Saudi princes those in their 50s and
60s the banders of the world you know
this family of 6,000 princes they don't
all feel the same about every issue they
don't feel the same about Israel they
don't feel the same about the United
States and what MD and and they do about
Wahhabi ISM so that what we should be
doing is reaching out to the moderates
they may not be moderate by our
standards they may not be moderate by
the standards of the Democratic Party
but they're moderate by the standards of
Wahhabi ISM those should be the ones
that were courting those should be the
ones that we're preparing for the future
for because if we don't what we will end
up with is an explosion in Saudi Arabia
in terms of the bottom overthrowing the
House of Saud and then we will have that
radical fundamentalist government that
makes even the current leaders seem
normal in comparison and when you're
talking about a third of the world's oil
supply I think that's too great a gamble
to take and I hope that you agree thank
you very much
now for those of you that I've
thoroughly confused questions are
welcome yes
you haven't mentioned the company that
Bush one is a partner in that does so
much business over there and that a lot
of other Americans having been in the
government are partners of and what role
they play The Carlyle Group yeah right
yes they are in the book even though I
left them out of this talk you're
absolutely right and right don't know
but you're right the Carlyle Group is an
interesting group it has former
government officials from both parties
there are Democrats in there as well but
primarily the Republicans are the big
hitters although John Major the former
prime minister of my wife's dear old
country England is now also a member the
and the Carlyle Group wield tremendous
influence one of my great problems with
the Carlyle Group aside from everything
else
it took a press report in The Wall
Street Journal the disclosure of the
fact after 9/11 that they had two
million dollars invested in them by the
bin Laden family not an enormous amount
of money we're talking billion dollar
company in the Carlyle Group small
investment by the bin Laden family and
I'm not talking about Osama writing a
check but the large construction company
that is the of which he is one of 27
Sons I've founded by his father that is
a multibillion-dollar entity the largest
construction company in all of Saudi
Arabia and two of the sons had invest in
the Carlyle Group now the problem with
that is in 1996 there was an indictment
against Osama bin Laden by a court in
New York the FBI had put him on their
own desk as a as a wanted man by the end
of 96 and by 97 the CIA was operating
its own station a bin Laden desk when he
flew in 96 from at that point to Sudan
up to Pakistan and Afghanistan shortly
after that we knew we made a mistake by
not getting him in the Sudan the Carlyle
Group is too smart too well-connected
not to have known that the name bin
Laden was not a good group to have money
in your company but it took them 9/11
and the disclosure in a public paper
before they did the right thing that
always bothered me it shows you that
their commitment was first to the
Prophet first always to the money first
to the investment
as opposed to what I call that
appearance of impropriety I don't think
in the end that George Bush and the Bush
family with its oil background has
anymore a craven relationship with the
Saudis than any other president has had
I think they've been equally bad through
past administrations but the question to
be asked is whether Bush should have a
different relationship post 9/11 that's
a completely different issue Rudolph
Giuliani you might remember I have a
chapter in here called the man who would
buy America about Prince Alwaleed the
sixth wealthiest man in the world a
multi billionaire who invest in America
like there's no tomorrow
he owns the Four Seasons he's got the
Fairmont Hotels he's got parts of
Disney's the second biggest shareholder
in Fox after Rupert Murdoch a Citicorp
he's an astonishing a buyer he's the one
who after 9/11 walked around the ruins
while the bodies were still there a few
days after with Rudolph Giuliani and in
offer and gave him a ten million dollar
check and then later in the day issued a
statement that said I hope the American
people realize that their policies
toward Palestinians are so terrible that
it causes actions like this and Giuliani
said how dare you blame us the Americans
for 9/11 here's your check back some of
you might recall that now that's a post
9-11 action that was different if a
Saudi multi billionaire had given an
American mayor ten million dollars
before for about any cause before 9/11
it would have gone into the city's
coffers without a question after 9/11
Giuliani thought he should behave
differently because it was a different
world and the question is whether the
Bush administration should be behaving
differently and I think the answer to
that is yes I think it not only should
the Bush administration be doing it but
so should any other it's also something
I was a lawyer I am a lawyer not having
been disbarred I'm not practicing but
the but the law we have a thing called
avoid the appearance of impropriety now
a lot of lawyers don't do that but
politicians should be especially aware
of that and because of Bush's family's
connections to oil
he should have even been more careful of
the associations with the Saudis but
instead he's done business as usual and
that's unfortunate yes
not directly related to what you just
said but do you have an opinion of why
Bush went to Iraq went to world island
boy I'll tell you my my opinion a dollar
will get you a cup of coffee right at
Starbucks because I was down there a lot
in Washington beforehand and I must tell
you that I hope it was over weapons of
mass destruction but they always had and
I must tell you also that I was wrong on
this issue if if you had talked to me
before the invasion in Iraq Trish and I
had been down to Washington we've been
talking to people in the State
Department we've been talking to people
in the Defense Department
we were both adamantly convinced the WMD
were in Iraq
you talked to these individuals and
there I don't care if you call it
groupthink or if they were looking for
the answers from the CIA that they
wanted and that's what they got from
intelligence analysts or whatever else
but there really was a feeling there was
no question in their minds that when
they got into Iraq they were gonna find
one of two things either real WMD or the
infrastructure for having created WMD
that was their active and ready to go
and the if if I had known if anybody had
known that the WMD was wrong that our
vaunted CIA couldn't get the
intelligence right that it was giving
the wrong information out then what
France in Germany was asking for
let's have 90 more days or 120 days
let's keep pushing seemed like a
no-brainer there was no rush at all so I
think that the main reason was they
thought they would find the WMD and then
the question is were there ancillary
reasons certainly Dick Cheney is smart
enough to understand that if we could go
into Iraq and create a friendly
government big if now with the
insurgency going on in the way it's
turned out they could be they should be
the second largest oil producer in the
world
that's what Iraq's oil reserves are like
so what are they producing under Saddam
Hussein in the oil it restriction is
very little if we could make them the
world's second biggest oil producer we
actually take away some of the power of
the Saudis the Saudis no longer have the
power at eight million barrels a day for
Rack is pumping out six but now it's an
unmitigated disaster because Iraq's
pumping out less oil than ever so if
that was one of the side effects of
going in certainly didn't turn out to be
the case and then that political science
I was a political science major the
political science goal of if we spark
democracy in the middle of
Arak it will spread around the Middle
East like flame and so the domino theory
in Reverse I've never been a big fan of
that I've always been sort of a thinker
that if anything you you know be careful
what you ask for because you may get it
and if we get democracy everywhere in
the Middle East we may find governments
that are not that favorable to us you
just saw on southern Lebanon in the
elections Hezbollah was winning who won
on the elections in Saudi Arabia for the
limited position of the provincial
council not the real estate developers
and some of the princes were actually
running but the hardcore real religious
fundamentalist I think if you had an
election tomorrow in the Palestinian
Authority Hamas would probably win so
you know democracy is a two-edged sword
because guess what the people get to
choose and there are a lot of angry
people in the Arab Street at the United
States and it's a problem yes it's
interested in your chapter that you
wrote about the Wahhabi lobbying about
the the Israel lobby and I was
interested in your opinion about why the
Israel lobby and I've been tracking this
since the early 1990s never goes after
Saudi Arabia at the most recent AIPAC
conference Iran was again at the top of
the agenda but in all the top and all
the lobbying there's never anything said
about Saudi Arabia now my theory is is
because one of the secrets of a pacts
effectiveness is that it doesn't tell
the administration anything it doesn't
want to hear is what what is your take
on it is it intimidation by the Wahhabi
Lobby is it just the fact that being
anti Iran because being anti Ron makes
you Pro Saudi at least in terms of our
government that it's somehow placates
the Saudis to have the US government be
so stridently anti
intimidation by the Wahhabi Lobby that
scares the Israelis off I think part of
it is and and I'm saying this without
knowing this is Apax reasons but from
watching them observing them and I agree
with you they aren't as aggressive with
Saudi Arabia as they are with many other
issues it's a matter of figuring out
where they can best spend their own
resources and their time and they do
they're very aggressive as you know on
many issues
let things off I think if they had an
even larger staff more time in there
were 26 hours in the day they might also
include Saudi Arabia but you have to
remember the Saudi Arabia has at times
although denies this adamantly
cooperated together with Israel remember
iran-contra and arms to Iran was a
backdoor way I mean it is interesting
that Saudi money bought the arms to a
third-party intermediary in Europe who
sent Israeli arms that were earmarked
for Israel from the United States over
to Iran shortly after Reagan came in
power although everybody denied having
anything to do with in all blamed on
Khashoggi who was the middleman so that
the the idea that the Saudis had
cooperated all with the Israelis had
anything to do with them was just you
know vehement Newsnight inside the
kingdom and the Israelis denied it as
well but the Saudis are pragmatist in
the end at least the salad family they
are really pragmatist and although
publicly they have come up with a peace
plan that may not seem very tenable as a
peace plan that says withdraw to the 67
borders and give up all Jerusalem and
that's not going to happen
implied in there is if you did that we
would recognize you which is heresy to
the bin Louden's in that of the world
they can't even believe that they've
gone to that extent so I believe that
Israel on the one hand will allow
someone like Dore gold to come out the
former Israeli ambassador to the United
States and publish a vitriolic book on
the Saudis that they hate to this day
and still as a matter of fact I've been
compared to gold so I know that's a good
sign
the so they will allow that to happen
but to write about AIPAC they have
generally been kind when it comes to the
Saudis and if they are using an efforts
behind the scenes yes yes right since a
was and he is absolutely true the and
and I'm not sure really if it's because
they think there are other fires that
are more important to fight first I'm
not sure yes what really bothers me is
that although we as the American
government has been friendly with the
Saudis since Roosevelt FDR we know that
the Bush family is particularly friendly
with the Saudis and the journalists and
the writers have not you know like
really like put that
there and I guess I'm very depressed
Democrat and liberal and progressive and
it
we know that the that excuse me the
Saudis were were at least eighty five
percent of the attackers on 9/11 and we
know that they that they definitely
supply them the terrorists with the
money and with wherewithal to do their
terroristic acts so it really bothers me
that although we know this we don't
really put it out there no I'm
infuriated by myself and I must tell you
it's very interesting we've talked about
this recently Tricia myself this has
been one of the most this is my tenth
book and this is one of the most
frustrating book tours in the sense that
we are talking to young producers on CNN
and Fox or wherever else on air America
saying here's the story on the Saudis
and their answer pretty much is G we
know that yeah this is there was a
review in The Washington Post a week ago
that said you'd have to be in a cave for
the last 40 years not to know the Saudis
are bad people this is all known but
I'll tell you something I must have been
in the cave because the telev went ahead
and did this research for tears I knew
they may not be the nicest people in the
world but a lot of this was news and the
things that aren't reported are really
interesting because they don't get any
coverage in 2001 before 9/11 the Crown
Prince Abdullah was really getting
infuriated about the u.s. position on
Israel
he was watching al-jazeera evidently and
seen the positions of the Intifada and
what was happening inside the
Palestinian Authority and was furious
over Jenin and he wrote a letter to Bush
the younger about how terrible the US
position was in Israel and how would
really strain Saudi relations with the
US and 9/11 came just after he had sent
that letter and so the Saudis weren't
able to push it but before 9/11 came
when the letter had arrived and before
Bush the younger head it's called Bush
the elder called up the South the crown
prince and said don't worry about my kid
in so many words he's got his heart in
the right place he'll come around he
knows what's happening I mean first of
all my father had done that if I had
been president United States I wanna
throttle him right for the embarrassment
but it's remarkable to think he talked
about the relationship with the Saudis
that the
father the forum president could feel
comfortable enough to call it the chrome
for instance they don't worry you know
he'll be okay and then you know one of
the things that it is a surprise to some
people in this if you've read senator
Graham's book that had been out or if
you read this and I go into this in
detail there are two people inside of
Southern California two Saudis who are
Saudi intelligence agents I say this I
say it all the time they haven't sued me
they keep denying it but okay one of
them by you me was working for the Saudi
Civil Air a BA ssin a government agency
receiving $2,800 a month and never
appear to work was just a it was a fake
job in which he got money to live on he
was reporting on Saudi dissidents in
Southern California that was his role
the second person was Omar Bosna these
two also a Saudi intelligence agent
Southern California now this is very
interesting two hijackers come into the
u.s. who were involved in 9/11 al al
murder and Al Hazmi they were at a
summit meeting in Malaysian Kuala Lumpur
in December of 1999 the CIA knew that
these two men from the Middle East they
didn't know who they were at the time
we're traveling up to Malaysia because
they had picked up intercepts of a known
terrorist leader in Malaysia talking to
these two guys the Middle East they
asked Malaysian intelligence to monitor
the meeting the malaysian intelligence
videotapes it but they don't have any
audio surveillance the CIA then gets
pictures of these two men for the middle
east they run them through all our
computers here in the US and identify
them from visa pictures because they
have permanent visas to the US and they
come and they enter the u.s. in January
of 2000 19 months before the 9/11 attack
so al Haas me and al mod are in the
country now there's a little problem on
it because the CIA doesn't tell anyone
and no one knows about until a month
before the attacks even though they're
living openly in San Diego and they have
driver's license and their own names and
they have social security cards they by
9800 to Corolla and they open a bank
account to the Bank of America that's
another story but here's the interesting
part about the Saudis the day that these
two men arrived at LAX they leave LAX
and they said let's go to a restaurant
we're hungry
there they go along and they find wood
looks like a Middle Eastern restroom
they go in there now on that same day by
you me who is a Saudi intelligence agent
goes and stops the Saudi embassy the
Saudi consulate and then goes out and
says he's hungry
sure drives like 40 miles out of his way
and ends up at the same restaurant
and he hears the two men behind him
talking Arabic and start to talk to them
and finds out they just arrived and as
he would do being a very friendly fellow
over the next year and a half he gives
them $40,000 so they can get settled in
the United States typical things that
you do when you run into a couple of
people from the old country
now the second fellow involved Boz Don
who had hosted a party once for Shaykh
Abdul Rahman you know the one-eyed
cleric was convicted for the day of
terrible potting in New York Boz Don's
wife has thyroid surgery in 98 and she
applies for charity from the Saudi
embassy which they do they give it they
give it away and Prince Bandar's wife
gives her money
twenty-five hundred dollars or three
thousand dollars a month in 98 for her
toward her offset her cost and then
after surgery he keeps coming 99 in 2000
2001 she doesn't need the money anymore
so she signs it over to buy ooh me who's
giving it on to the two hijackers now it
looks like possibly a backdoor way of
getting official money of the hijackers
so why don't we ask Baz down in bio me
well they're back in Saudi Arabia and
the justice minister nyah if the
interior minister who thinks that Israel
and the Mossad was behind 9/11 has said
so says we aren't extraditing them and
hasn't let us officials interrogate them
now I can assure you if this was any
other country than Saudi Arabia we'd be
screaming we'd be slamming our fists
down and yet I'm not seeing it I'm
having trouble getting this information
on in between coverage of the Jackson
trial on CNN or runaway bride or that so
you know it is a frustrating process
because we will focus on this issue if
it is given to us on a silver platter
and one of the things that's happened I
think is that you know you aren't the
group I should be talking to the very
fact that you're here means you're
interested in this subject you're
following it in some ways the people
that should be listening to her
somewhere outside but you know you can't
do it so that in a sense we become we're
talking to ourselves but it's a very
frustrating process and I don't know if
those two people are involved in 9/11 or
if they knew what the hijackers are up
to or anything else but I know we don't
have the answers to it and are we
pursuing it evidently not
yes
energies required to run the Commerce in
this country without energy we stop we
don't like atomic energy we don't want
to do anymore drilling
how tough do you think we can really be
with the Saudis when they happen to be I
think our major supplier I don't know
what fortune is supply there's a lot
it's right it's down believe it or not
the good news is for us it's down to 17
percent the bad news for Western Europe
it's still about 30 35 percent for
France and Germany in other countries so
but since we're all tied together
economically if Western Europe goes in
the toilet I guess we're not far behind
but you're absolutely right if we were
tough with them and I don't mean tough
to the point of saying okay we're not
buying your oil unless tomorrow you
start to have democratic style elections
and you like women have the right to
drive forget the right to vote right to
drive might be nice as tough as they
want to be with us they still want to
make the money so they still want to
sell to us that's the interesting thing
the amazing thing about Saudi Arabia
that really did come as a shock was that
for 19 of the last 20 years they've run
a budget deficit yeah is it really
remarkable that they have a two hundred
billion dollar deficit that they spend
they continue to spend a third of the
country's income on military technology
and schools and hospitals get less and
less to 25 percent yeah well we spend it
as fast as it comes in right on all the
newest tech toys for military I agree
but the amazing thing is that they've
squandered much of the wealth of the
country so they need this money the $50
oil helps them get back in the black as
it is so they want to sell to us it's
going to take a pretty grievous error on
our end to have them actually turn
around and not sell the so I think that
the question is this is a side question
that we have to ask ourselves isn't it
great that we are having this war I just
you know you read about the five young
soldiers killed the other day in the
bomb that just exploded that we're
having a war where body bags are coming
back of men and women in this war in
Iraq we're spending another 90 billion
dollars on it and yet we here in the
country don't have to make any sacrifice
it's the first war I've ever known of in
which a presidents never said by the way
you know you're gonna have forget
rations you're just gonna have to cut
back a little bit I mean after 9/11 we
were told to support the economy show
our patriotism Garland's shop today
there's no talk even about putting back
a 55 mile an hour speed limit you know
we did that after the oil embargo to
save millions of gallons
maybe it wouldn't be past but nobody
even mentions it as a possibility no one
says you don't need your second SUV or
anything like that because we don't need
conservation you know that's not the so
I'm I don't know why we're not asked on
our end
not that we're gonna solve the problem
to make a little bit of help toward the
end oh one more question then I'll also
stay afterwards to those of you who will
want to come up yes yeah I was gonna say
this kind of a little background um you
know with Noriega he was our ally with
the Panama Canal but when he turned
against us like when you know capturing
the hostages and and everything else he
was our best friend we did deals with
him he fought the conscious for us but
you know in politics if you wanted a
friend get a dog as they say so he was
our enemy so how come this didn't apply
also to Saudi Arabia like say okay now
you're our enemy now and we're sending
in the 82nd airborne well I think that
the Saudis had been clever enough to
make sure that we are convinced in
Washington that we need them and that
means the House of Saud and they've done
it very very well even though through 92
99 is now fairly clear evidence that
they allowed money to continue to flow
to al-qaeda in the hope that al Qaeda
wouldn't bring the war back to them
that's sort of like in the past its
forgiven now and I do think that behind
the scenes well they aren't doing it
publicly the Saudis provide some help
that the Americans are pleased with him
give you a perfect example in the Iraq
war the Saudis allowed us transport some
planes to take off from Saudi bases and
they provided they allowed a wax access
to Saudi airspace and they gave us some
logistical support as well they didn't
advertise it because they don't want the
person on the street who really doesn't
like America that much to know they were
helping America fight a Muslim brother
but they gave enough help to the
administration the administration could
say you know what these guys really
aren't that bad after all
so whereas Noriega actually became an
enemy in that sense to the Saudis
they're just smart enough to know when
to clap us on the back and give us a
bone or two and then at the other hand
play tough and when we criticize him
over something they say we're working on
it last thing and then
let you be free with all of this but
every server something more uplifting a
few days ago you may have seen that the
State Department issued a report that
actually for the first time it actually
lifted by buoyed by spirits they they
said the Saudi Arabia is one of four
Arab countries of 14 nations that
sanctions may eventually be put against
because of human trafficking women who
were brought in for sex trade or third
world migrants who were brought in as
indentured servants I thought that's
really remarkable that they were allowed
to include Saudi Arabia's normally we
never include them on the list like
that's the first time I've seen that the
Saudis denied it the but see this is
very typical Saudi first two days they
said this is just rubbish you know I
mean how did our name get listed on this
country it's not true then like in the
last couple of days they've issued a
couple of statements and said you know
what you our American friends you're
clever we'll look into it and if there's
anything here we'll make sure that we'll
take care of it so they know how to play
us eventually so now they'll look into
that for the next ten years
remember this was a country that didn't
ban slavery and so Jack Kennedy asked
for it is they had banned slavery
officially in the 1940s but slaves
continued to exist every every prominent
Saudi family had a black slave in Saudi
Arabia when the crown prince came to New
York and stayed the Waldorf and brought
his slave Murdoch it was like a big
cause of consternation and Kennedy
actually asked them to officially end it
and they did so they were late to the
game but they you know that's their sort
of answer is we're working on it and
they pulled that one on us for a long
time all right thank you very much thank
you
Gerald Posner is author of nine books
including why America slept the failure
to prevent 9/11 and case closed
Lee Harvey Oswald and the assassination
of JFK his latest secrets of the kingdom
is published by Random House visit at
random comm for more information